your book kind of expands on the
definition of an unplugged Alpha and you
know you're pretty much saying that um
an unplugged outfit is you know striving
for excellence
um not making a female as a uh priority
within their life span and um and always
um I guess remain within a purpose
um like um you know just give me your
your your personal perspective on that
like I can only paraphrase the best I
could with my ability and um you know
just give us a little more breakdown on
your definition of the unplug Alpha
so there's four quadrants there's
um there's alphas and there's betas and
there's plugged in and there's unplugged
so you can have a plugged in beta and
unplug beta a plugged in Alpha and an
unplugged Alpha all right there's
natural Alphas out there that are
plugged in you know they're uh
successful people they're usually big
and strong they're influential
um there's probably loads of athletes
that you know you can think of right now
that marry the wrong woman and they give
up half their [__] to some somebody that
you know divorces them 10 11 years down
the road sort of thing so there's
different quadrants to it but the
unplugged Alpha is
basically the guy that that sees the
code in The Matrix that understands what
the world's really about you know the
lies that have been shelled to them
through government through uh culture
through marketing through education
through religion through all these
different aspects and sees through the
the uh [__] basically and puts
themselves first you know makes
themselves the most important part the
most important component of everyday
decisions and life choices and how
they're going to direct their lives and
where they're going to go and
um
there's components of that when you deal
with circle of influences like friends
and women and you know the like that's
you that you set boundaries around right
like an unplugged Alpha is not going to
invite a crazy woman into their life
there's a chapter on my book on um funny
Red Flags uh and unplugged off is not
going to invite a woman that's got you
know 15 of those red flags in their
lives marry them and put babies in them
because that is just about the dumbest
thing that you can do so
the book covers a lot of those elements
right it's it's something that you
really have to dive into the rabbit hole
on to fully understand
right and um
man I like the way you broke that down
cause it's uh digestible for the you
know I get I don't want to say beta male
but
um a male that's not um knowledgeable
about those words of wisdom that you
just drop right now and um my other
question for you now is um why do you
think
um some certain
um males that's uh select a selective
male would invite
um crazy women into their lives like why
why do you think they make foolish
decisions like that
that's a couple things the scarcity they
don't have an abundance mindset they
just you know the first girl that
touches her pee pee they want to get
married to or you know make them their
girlfriend sort of thing these guys are
mostly Geeks
um
and then there's the other component
which is probably the most uh
weighted part I would say it's just all
the [__] we've been sold our lives
you know the story about one man one
woman uh you know you take your vows
till death do us part and good in
sickness and health and richer and
poorer and blah blah blah uh there's all
kinds of narratives that you hear like
you've heard people say things like
happy wife happy life well I don't know
a single guy that said happy wife happy
life that's in an actual happy marriage
where they're getting enthusiastic sex
from their wife on a regular basis
they're usually getting brow beat by
their wives and treated like crap so
there's the there's those two elements
and when they kind of like mash up
that's what creates a lot of problems
and I'd say probably the vast majority
of society like 85 to 95 percent of guys
out there are would be in that category
there's very few guys that are on that
are unplugged from The Matrix I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clips
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out